the hypocrisy just doesn't end with
these people and you know my friend
michael malus
often says and walter kern who was on
the show a couple weeks ago on our
friday panel
makes the point of saying that something
good is happening right now because the
lies are just coming out faster and
faster so
sort of like the first segment i did on
aoc it's like everyone knows you're
lying about all that stuff
not everyone but a lot of people fouchy
you flip flop
every which way it's like you guys are
red pilling people left and right
because
the average person has some uh memory
right we have some memory of you saying
one thing and then saying another thing
and everything else
so here is fauci now saying that mass
mandates for fully vaccinated americans
are going to be quite understandable
whack
so it's quite understandable neil why
local authorities are now
saying good that you're vaccinated but
in a situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask
good that you're vaccinated but people
indoors
should wear a mask that local
authorities should be deciding that well
guys science tells us the vaccine works
right isn't that what he's telling us so
if you're vaccinated
you should be allowed to be out there
we're also told now the new thing is
that
uh that the vaccine doesn't really stop
the delta variant which everyone's
freaking over but you will get
less lesser symptoms in essence okay
i think they're missing the point here
i'm going to actually try to give fauchi
the benefit of the doubt which it's
getting very hard to do
but the point that they're missing is
that humans need to
move on we need to move on from this
right
some people are going to get sick it is
possible that
uh that kovid will be with us in some
form or another forever at this point
and there will be people
who get sick there will people who get
different variants maybe it will
morph into something else you should
take whatever precautions you want to
take
you know my feelings about vaccines and
if you want to wear masks and all of
those things
but the fact that still now we are over
a year and a half
after two weeks to flatten the curve and
now he's
kind of saying yeah if you're indoors
wear a mask even if you're vaccinated
it's like when does life
ever become normal again and then
there's these other people that'll say
well no this is the new normal
and again guys if you could snap your
fingers if you could snap your fingers
and go back to a year and a half ago
would you do it
go back to that life a year and a half
ago would you do it i think pretty much
everybody would
except our ruling class except the
fouchies except the democrat
governors except the people who want to
endlessly control you i can tell you
here in los angeles
where now there is an indoor mask
mandate whether you're vaccinated or not
well first off a lot of people aren't
doing it the sheriff has said he will
not enforce it
i went into the mall i did not wear a
mask
some people were marrying me where were
wearing masks some people were not
wearing masks
and when you see someone who's not
wearing a mask there's a nice human
moment and you can actually see them
smile because you can see their mouth
it's quite extraordinary actually
because human interaction
and us being social creatures is an
important part of the whole damn thing
um when i went into bloomingdale's i
went into bloomingdale's to get a
bathing suit because i'm going off the
grid
i did not have a mask on a sales
associate came up to me very nicely he
said sir could you put on your mask and
i did because i was not there to get
into a fight with this guy or get this
guy fired or any bit of trouble
or have them call the police even though
we know the police won't won't do
anything about it
but i think you can do what is right for
you in your life i'm not being a dick
about it i'm actually going to get the
the antibody test later today at 3 30 so
stay tuned
on that because everyone has to make
decisions for themselves anyway i want
to show you some other
tweets that we've got here so back in
march of 2020
people were saying very very different
things this is
chris hayes trump's obsession focus on a
vaccine is nuts
it's totally immaterial to the
short-term challenges
which are substantial now i want you to
really think about that let's leave that
up for just a second
uh this is back basically a little over
a year ago
when trump was pushing for a vaccine and
you've got the
eight o'clock i guess he guess he's on
this guy's on at eight o'clock i don't
know what time chris hayes is on nobody
nobody really knows what times chris
hayes is on and nobody should know
but basically he's saying that trump
because he's pushing for a vaccine is
nuts these are the very same people who
all want you to get
vaccinated immediately right now he
slightly has walked back from that on
twitter over the last couple days
then there's that that real uh
piece of work joy read over on msnbc and
this is when trump
was president the trump administration
has so
broken the federal government and
several state governments
thanks to sycophantic governors like ron
desantis brian kemp
greg abbott christie nome etc etc i
can't even conceive
how we put it back together and restore
credibility i mean will
anyone anyone at all ever fully trust
the cdc again
and who on god's earth would trust a
vaccine approved by the fda
how do we get a vaccine distributed
after this broken trumpist nonsense has
infected everything
even if biden wins really think about
that think about the level
of partisan insanity that these people
pushed out there
we have chris hayes basically saying
trump's focusing on a vaccine and that's
going to kill people and this woman
saying
joy reid saying we can't even trust the
cdc anymore because of trump
these are the same exact people who now
will tell you everything that the cdc is
right and that of course you should get
vaccinated and it's the unvaccinated
people
who are the problem even though it was
them telling people we're focusing too
much on vaccines and vaccines are
probably evil
because of trump this is what causes
people to have bipolar disorder i'm
fairly certain like if you watch these
people
the way they flip-flop you know it's one
thing to change your opinion i hear this
often
well dave you changed your opinion on
things you used to be a bernie
supporting leftist we've seen the videos
on youtube
i'm not proud of those videos by the way
uh but you know what happened to me
i got new information like that seminal
moment that all of you have seen when i
sat down with larry elder talking about
systemic racism
and i couldn't back up my position and
larry had facts and information
that's not flip-flopping when you evolve
to a new position because of new
information
flip-flopping is when because one guy
you don't like says something you say
something and then when the guy you like
says something you say something else
and that's what all of these
people are doing we'll throw rachel
maddow in there too we've got
a maddow tweet trump has plotted
with his team on a pre-election
promotional campaign
to try to convince voters a vaccine is
safe approved and ready for mass
distribution
even if none of that is true yet well of
course
as we know it turned out to be
completely true and it's exactly the
same vaccine that they are trying to
push
on everybody right now
you